[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti mi chiamo
matteo moretti e sono ricercatori della
libera università di bolzano dove mi
occupo di viso al giornalismo
innanzitutto cos'è il viso del
giornalismo è una pratica a cavallo tra
design e giornalismo che racconta fatti
complessi a un pubblico più ampio in
maniera più diciamo accessibile opere
anche più coinvolgente nel nostro lavoro
collaboriamo spesso con vari
professionisti con designer e
giornalisti ovviamente ma anche con
sociologi antropologi psicologi
fotografi programmatori questo proprio
per raccontare fenomeni complessi
attraverso più sfaccettature possibili
proprio per riportare in maniera
accessibile la complessità moderna
oggi vorrei parlarvi di un progetto
fatto un anno fa ma che si chiama europa
dreaming è una sorta di documentario on
line o un'inchiesta multimediale che si
avvale di elementi interattivi video
infografiche per fare emergere una
narrazione differente su quella che è
stata la crisi dei migranti del 2005
2015 come viene chiamata o forse è
meglio la crisi dell'europa del 2015 per
mano dei migranti
sì perché è quello che cerca di fare il
progetto è chiedersi che fine ha fatto
il sogno europeo
non so se vi ricordate quando si parlava
di sogno europeo era il 1995 entrava in
vigore il trattato di schengen che
promuoveva la libera parte la libera
circolazione tra i vari paesi europei
ben attualmente diciamo il sogno europeo
si sta sgretolando messi in crisi dal
sogno dei migranti e questa è la domanda
proprio che apre il progetto cosa
succede in questo scontro di sogni
una delle conseguenze queste ad esempio
questa è un'immagine molto forte non so
se la conoscete viene chiamata la marcia
dei migranti sono circa un migliaio di
migranti siriani che scappando dalla
siria e cercando di raggiungere il nord
europa dove presentare una richiesta
d'asilo vengono bloccati in ungheria dal
governo
yourban rimangono bloccati in una
stazione ferroviaria per molti giorni
finché angela merkel lo fa un annuncio
abbastanza forte dice tutti rifugiati
siriani richiedenti asilo siriani che
riusciranno arrivare in germania avranno
riconosciuto lo status di rifugiato
questo scatena immediatamente una
reazione e loro decidono autonomamente a
piedi di continuare il loro percorso di
attraversare l'altra metà dell'europa
l'immagine di per sé molto forte ma
diventa ancora più forte se ci
concentriamo su chi sta guidando questa
marcia è un uomo che sventrò una
bandiera europea
allora io non so quanti di voi abbiano a
casa una bandiera europea io per primo
non ce l'ho e mai ho pensato di averne
una forse perché non mi sento così
europeo si faccia parte dell'europa ma
mi sento italiano
eppure questo tema ricorrente
dell'europa tornava continuamente in
tutti gli scambi che abbiamo avuto anche
con i migranti che abbiamo incontrato
nel progetto ad esempio lui ci ha detto
in europa
avete i diritti umani che è una cosa che
noi diamo per scontata ma in realtà non
è assolutamente scontata in tre quarti
di mondo un altro ci ha detto sono salvo
perché finalmente sono arrivato in
europa e non in italia
apparentemente a tutte queste
testimonianze abbiamo cominciato a
riflettere perché attraverso le loro
testimonianze era sempre più forte e
chiara questa idea che il sogno europeo
in qualche modo nelle loro mani perché
loro credono molto di più di noi
nell'europa dovremmo essere noi quelli
che portano avanti il sogno in realtà
noi siamo percepiti esternamente come
europei e come europa nonostante noi non
ci crediamo ma loro ci credono molto più
di noi ma poi soprattutto di coloro pa
stiamo parlando forse l'europa che ha
discusso tantissimo sul ruolo della
grecia e ha votato anche per espellere
la grecia dell'europa perché non
risparmiano non rispettava i parametri
economici oppure un europa che non ha
assolutamente discusso o discussi minima
parte e non assolutamente votato
sull'espulsione dell'ungheria che non
stava rispettando i diritti umani in
materia di profughi sì infatti ci
troviamo davanti a un unione diciamo più
economica piuttosto che un unione
europea assolutamente un'unione
umanitaria infatti uno degli aspetti
diciamo che il progetto far emergere fa
emergere è la mancanza di una unitarietà
ogni nazione ogni stato membro
agisce secondo gli interessi nazionali e
non secondo gli interessi di una di una
comunità e questo ovviamente crea
ulteriore confusione e alimenta
narrazioni tossiche e senza
sensazionalismi che portano poi ad
allontanarci dal sogno europeo
forse un uno dei sensazionalismi più
eclatanti e questo eclatante perché
avviene proprio per mano dell'europa
stessa
questa è la pagina di frontex frontex
l'agenzia devota al controllo degli
accessi sul territorio europeo
che tradotto vuol dire conta quante
persone entrano in europa
e proprio in quell ottobre del 2015
dichiara che 710 mila migranti sono
entrati sul suolo europeo nei primi nove
mesi non appena pubblica la notizia su
twitter la risposta che ho anzi la
domanda di nando sigona che ha un
ricercatore in ambito migratorio non si
fa attendere
come fate esser sicuri che questo sia il
numero corretto nel momento in cui i
migranti sbarcano in grecia non sono
identificati e dopo di che nel loro
percorso verso il nord europa vengono
contati più volte perché più volte
entrano i loro apa scavalcando diversi
confini
dopo un po frontex risponde dice i
nostri rilievi contano quante persone
entrano in europa quindi con molta
serenità ammettono che le persone
arrivate in grecia sono state nuovamente
contate una volta entrata in ungheria
a quel punto nando sigona dice bene
quindi significa che il numero reale
in realtà è decisamente inferiore perché
a voi avete contato due volte ed è così
che frontex poi aggiunge questa
dichiarazione in fondo all'articolo che
vi riporto qui di regola parte in bianco
che è quella più importante e dice
questo significa che un largo numero di
persone che sono state contate al loro
ingresso in grecia sono stati nuovamente
contatti quando sono entrate in unione
europea per la seconda volta attraverso
l'ungheria la croazia
sì perché
quando si parla di europa si parla di
tre di schengen e non tutti i paesi
aderiscono a schengen
quindi ci sono dei buchi significa
quindi che i circa 800 mila profughi
sbarcati in grecia nel 2015
poi sono stati nuovamente contatti
quando si sono spostati cercando di
raggiungere il nord europa quindi
attraversando la macedonia sono usciti
dall'europa per poi rientrare nuovamente
in croazia e ungheria
e questo è un problema perché come fa se
possiamo parlare di immigrazione di
asilo politico di europa se nemmeno
l'agenzia europea devota a contare gli
accessi è in grado di farlo per questo
motivo noi non abbiamo usato i dati ma
in un altro modo assolutamente diverso
proprio perché è impossibile parlare di
dati in maniera pulita e trasparente e
cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo preso i dati
relativi agli sbarchi mettendo in
relazione con quelli dei paesi in cui
sono state presentate le richieste
d'asilo creando quindi un ponte tra i
paesi di sbarco e paese in cui veniva
chiesto l'asilo politico mostrando come
ci fossero delle incongruenze non sono
gli stessi e questo è un ulteriore
problema che emerge sì perché secondo il
trattato di schengen
il profugo che sbarca ad esempio in
grecia dovrà poi presentare la sua
richiesta di asilo politico in grecia e
non potrà uscire dalla grecia
ma quello che poi ha venduto in
quell'anno sappiamo tutti le persone si
sono spostate all'interno
dell'europa maniera
se controllata così la visualizzazione
inizia mostrando questa nuvola
la cosa certa sappiamo di circa un
milione di profughi sono sbarcati loro
alla visualizzazione assolutamente anti
scientifica anzi direi proprio
emozionale
dice veramente poco e piuttosto confusa
e l'aspetto dire seguire questa
confusione visiva e proprio voluto è
proprio la volontà di trasmettere un
esperienza quella della difficoltà nel
quantificato
cosa certo c'è una massa di persone
quando il pallino indicative di graffi e
queste persone sono difficili da
localizzare perché sì sappiamo che sono
sbarcati in grecia perché sono i puntini
rosa o in italia in spagna tutti gli
spalatori che non sappiamo come si sono
mosse ma questo è solo un dettaglio
capiamo la visualizzazione come dicevo è
molto complessa e quindi vediamo come
queste persone poi si sono andate a
distribuire nei vari paesi e quindi
scopriamo ad esempio in germania non ci
sono stati ovviamente sbarchi immigrati
ma costante questo quasi mezzo milione
di persone hanno presentato la domanda
di asilo politico
quello che è successo in italia navona o
nelle diverse ci sono stati circa 150
mila sbarchi è più o meno la metà delle
richieste d'asilo quindi vuol dire che
non è
se persone sbarcate in italia si sono
spostate il caso più forte ovviamente
quello della grecia in cui sono stati
registrati quasi 800mila smarchino e
solo 11 mila richieste resi questo per
un motivo molto semplice perché è
tuttora abitata europa non è vita e
quindi ogni paese europeo offre
condizioni tempi diversi in merito al
processo a cessare la richiesta di asilo
abbiamo quindi precisate
ai vari pezzi mostrano poco nonostante
se sei mesi quindi questa bolla quota e
mezzi da tempo che una volta suggerisce
non mette un pò meglio per processare
una richiesta d'asilo e ci sono pezzi
come francia e germania che possono
indicare fino a sette mesi per farlo
altri paesi come l'italia che ci mettono
quasi due anni max 2 anni massimo paesi
come il regno unito 5 che impiegano fino
a 3 anni e quindi ovvio che persone che
una richiesta d'asilo rappresenteranno
in un paese prof e tetti indici oli
sicuramente e condizioni migliori ma
batte 2 a mettervi nei panni una persona
che vive poi costretto a vivere italia
prima di saltare sempre potrà continuare
ad essere italiana supplente dopo di che
oltre ai dati abbiamo cercato di
raccontare anche come questo fenomeno
come diciamo questo problema dell'europa
avesse radici profonde e per farlo non
abbiamo usato i dati non ricerca del
figlio perché abbiamo scoperto una cosa
molto particolare legata la città di
multimedia
non so se vi ricordate le foto di dello
scontro tra tendopoli
sugli scogli di ventimiglia che sono
sommano giro le testate internazionali
i profughi sbarcati in italia si sono
recate in francia per presentare la loro
domanda di asilo sono stati respinti si
sono accampati sui muscoli minuti media
pochi giorni dopo la polizia ha generato
in malo modo la cosa non assolutamente
perché sempre detto è stato teatro di un
altro scontro vent'anni prima di
profughi questa volta dell'ex jugoslavia
che si recavano nei moti fra accettarla
domanda d'asilo a in quell'anno era
entrato in vigore sheng quindi
permetteva l'accesso all'interno
dell'europa che apparteneva allo stato
metodo di chi nonostante ruolo l'ex
jugoslavia a partire ma geograficamente
all'europa non in parte loro non poteva
mancare vent'anni poco è cambiato tutto
ora le stesse animati che si ripetono
perché schengen tutto lana in grado di
affrontare sistema e questo c'era ma
vede sempre
in maniera diciamo emergenziale tuttora
di paese continua a fare i propri
interessi e solo così sta man mano
allontanano ma è tutto questo ci sono
anche aspetti positivi e uno di questi
muri e condividerlo con voi questa è una
testimonianza molto breve di un ragazzo
che uno dei tanti che abbiamo
intervistato che cercava di oltrepassare
il confine di prenderlo e ci ha detto
una cosa molto particolare era in uso
non abbia rispetto alle sfere che
abbiamo sentito dagli altri nove grazia
mente ringrazia tutti noi
ecco quello che dividevo con voi
diciamo due robot atto della serie mercy
dei romeni
da allora c'erano e se tutto proprio
caro piero
vastissimo 17 par suo tour in america lo
chalet reimers il plasma di te io mi
sono fatto vieta
ma c'è una parte se ne rimasi
nessun piacere ogni 7 ottobre europea
con fondi
il motion gaming e giulio ii oggi sia
fuori di testà serbo a tutte le
periferie
vai dentro quindi con questo augurio
vorrei lasciarvi con un piccolo monito
perché se anche voi credete nel sogno
europeo poi ognuno è libero di credere
in quello che vuole io ci credo però
importante crederci veramente nella vita
di tutti i giorni
quindi quello che che noi facciamo in
quello che pensiamo e anche ovviamente
in quello che condividiamo sui social
network perché parafrasando d'azeglio si
potrebbe dire che è fatta europa bisogna
fare gli europei e vorrei aggiungere
quindi grando ponti e non muri
grazie
[Applauso]